اشباه الموصلات هي تلك الرقائق السوداء
التي تصنع من السيليكون لتتحكم في مرور
التيار الكهربائي ولا يعمل اي جهاز
الكتروني من دونها الرقائق دقيقه الحجم
تدخل في كثير من الصناعات الالكترونيه
كالهواتف الذكيه والحواسيب والسيارات
والطائرات والشبكات المعلوماتيه وصولا
لاجهزه العاب الفيديو ويبلغ حجم سوق
الرقائق العالميه نحو 430 مليار دولار
الصين تستهلك نحو 60% من الانتاج العالمي
لاشباه الموصلات بينما تهيمن تايوان على
نحو 60% من اجمالي التصنيع العالمي لتلك
الرقائق وتعتبر شركه تايوان لتصنيع اشباه
الموصلات الكبرى عالميا بقيمه سوقيه
تتجاوز 600 مليار دولار
الولايه المتحده تستورد من تايوان 90% من
استهلاكها من تلك الرقائق ما يعد وقع
وزيره التجاره الامريكيه ثغره امنيه تلك
المخاوف الامريكيه دفعت واشنطن لتخصيص 52
مليار دولار لدعم قطاع الرقائق
الالكترونيه على اراضيها كما انها اوقفت
تصدير الرقائق واشباه الموصلات الى الصين
كجزء من حرب تكنولوجيه تشنها على